hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so a few weeks ago I
shared my recipe for my watermelon fries
but of course these are no longer called
watermelon fries they're watermelon
fingers now or legs or or sticks or
hockey sticks HD double I don't know
what they are but they're not watermelon
fries on my channel anymore because
people were so mad about it I get it we
don't want to mess with fries fries are
holy in their own right so today I want
to share my recipe for real fries so I'm
doing fries two ways we've got some
sweet potato fries and some russet
potato fries and they're getting paired
with my no added sugar ketchup
now ketchup is pretty much a food group
in my home we love ketchup I love
ketchup and now that I my mom my kid
loves ketchup but I want to create a
ketchup recipe that I felt really good
about giving him because a lot of the
store-bought options are packed with
corn syrup and tons of salt and
additives I wanted something that was
really made with all the ingredients
that I would be feeding him anyways at
home not only am i putting this of
course on my french fries but we're
putting on on eggs we put it on burgers
on grilled cheese on mac and cheese all
the good things in life
deserve an equally good ketchup and this
ketchup is not just for kids either I
hosted a brunch last weekend and I
served this ketchup and everybody was
all over it super delish on little home
fry action so let's get to them
to make my fries I cut my potatoes into
quarter-inch thick fries I'm using both
russet potatoes and sweet potatoes then
I place them in a bowl and microwave
them for five minutes covered in plastic
wrap carefully remove the plastic wrap
and block them very well on paper towel
next I grease my pan lightly with a
little bit of oil and pop it into a
425-degree oven to preheat I like to
preheat my pan because it means that the
second that the potatoes hit the pan
they get crispy and golden brown then in
a bowl I mixed together cornstarch salt
some more oil and I toss the potatoes
with the mixture
at the 15-minute mark I take my potatoes
out of the oven and give them a good
flip and for the rest potatoes I add
some black pepper and thyme
and for the sweet potatoes I add some
cinnamon and chili
and I pop them back into the oven for 10
to 15 minutes until golden brown next
let's make my no sugar out of ketchup a
little bit of oil to a medium skillet
over medium-low heat
add in your chopped onion and cook until
it begins to caramelize about 45 to 50
minutes then I add the garlic and cook
until very aromatic sweet and care wise
about another 15 minutes
next I add some tomato paste posada some
chopped dates apple cider vinegar
balsamic vinegar dried allspice dried
cloves dried oregano and some fresh
thyme leaves I give that a good stir and
let it cook on low for about 15 minutes
until the dates are very soft next I
transfer it to my blender and I add a
little bit of salt and some pepper just
a taste
and I puree that until it's really
smooth yay Friday time real fries
[Music]
no no no no no no no mm-hmm
that's my frie voice alright guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your go-to fry dip
are you into mayo or ketchup or barbecue
sauce or honey or chimichurri or
something fancy-pants like that I want
to know also are you team sweet potato
or regular potato sweet potato regular
potato I can't choose so I'm honestly
just gonna have both of them today with
my ketchup but I love to hear from you
so definitely leave a comment below and
of course subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]